m
tout va bien monsieur
nom de dieu
je crois que j'ai blessé un homme
si je suis avec lorraine
les habitants de brookfield sont sous le
choc d'abord appris le meurtre en plein
après-midi de bruno sol
la cour reconnaît l'existence de dieu
chaque fois qu'un témoin jure de dire la
vérité
je pense qu'il est temps que l'acceptent
de l'existence du diable
je ne sais pas ce qui va arriver mais
tout ce qui s'est passé ce jour là
c'était parler
[Musique]
c'est un totem de sorcières on pense que
votre famille a été moteur et que c'est
envoûtement est toujours bénéfique
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est la réalité
je vois des choses que les autres ne m'a
pas voir
[Musique]
une chose horrible s'est produite ici
à mettre satanisme est un adversaire
qu'il faut prendre au sérieux
elle raconte moi
dans les délais
il faut que tu reviennes
la plus perdre pour le sauver
parce que c'est ce que ça peut vous
coûter
leurs ailes
[Musique]